I want to hear you work out drinking in  a picture behind me Fidel here at the  Grammy Awards and you know they seems  like what here's that world a commercial  break right yeah the cameras are off so  I thought and we're on commercial break  for the Grammy Awards no way here's my  chance they don't let you drink at the  Grammys really and it's long and so I  think they're afraid of everyone getting  saucy and so really that's better than  television certain people that sneak  things I don't know any of those people  out here I will not stop talking until  you subscribe to my youtube channel  that's right and I could talk a lot  seriously not gonna stop yep still here  not going anywhere I see you don't walk  away from this